a great look into the chaos that is
taking place behind the scenes at the
White House came to us yesterday in the
form of a Vanity Fair article by Gabriel
Sherman and one interesting little
tidbit is that Donald Trump has pulled
Rudy Giuliani off of Fox News
appearances again because they are so
disastrous this actually is not the
first time that this has happened you
might remember back in March we did a
story called what happened to Rudy
Giuliani because we noticed that after
some embarrassing television appearances
by Rudy he suddenly just wasn't being
interviewed anywhere a period and this
lasted for some months eventually Rudy
resurfaced but it is now happening again
now the public facing funny part is
there's old Rudy making a fun of making
a fool of himself on television yet
again all the time he's contradicting
himself he's self incriminating he's
admitting to things that Trump is still
publicly denying we've got to get Rudy
off of TV but then there's the more sort
of serious behind-the-scenes piece which
is predictable which is that people
around Donald Trump including Jared
Kushner his son-in-law and Ivanka Trump
his daughter have been telling Trump
you've got a fire Rudy for the better
part of a year according to this report
in Vanity Fair by Gabriel Sherman now of
course Trump has not fired Rudy but
there have been questions as to is Rudy
still Trump's lawyer or not but there's
more and more speculation that Rudy
Giuliani could end up arrested over the
Ukraine fiasco as two of his associates
already have Trump has stood by Rudy so
far but the pressure has mounted more
and more and now Donald Trump has at
least in the immediate told Rudy
Giuliani no more Fox News appearances
for you this has been corroborated
seemingly anyway circumstantially by Fox
News producers who said to Vanity Fair
you know in the last few days we
actually did invite Rudy Giuliani to
appear and he turned us down so it seems
as though this is indeed what's going on
one Republican is quoted by Gabriel
Sherman in this article as saying quote
Rudy is cut off from Fox News now
there's a second layer of funny and when
you look at what was the last straw or
the straw that broke the camel's back on
this it is something really really funny
at every appearance Rudy has been a
pathetic joke but what push Trump over
the edge is reportedly when Rudy went on
TV on November 23rd and said I have an
insurance policy against Trump in case
he turns on me that did not go over well
Rudy later tweeted that the that the
comment was a joke it was sarcastic it
wasn't for real but Trump didn't like it
and at that point said no more fox news
for Rudy Giuliani's so as usual with
Trump it's yes of course have Rudy do
interviews was always a bad idea your TV
lawyer can't seem to help but further
incriminate himself and you
but then the acute reason that actually
got Rudy pulled off is less about
incriminating Trump but merely saying
something that was supposedly a joke
that Trump didn't like which is oh if
chrome turns on me I've got an insurance
policy against him it's a never ending
comedy of errors it's a race to the
bottom so to speak in political
discourse so now let's step back for a
second at this point isn't it clear that
Rudy is going to eventually be thrown
under the bus by Donald Trump I know
that right now it's a fight we can't
tell are they going to remain friends
loyal to each other or not if I were
Rudy I think I'd be realizing at this
point that I might be able to avoid it
for a little while but ultimately this
is going to end poorly with Donald Trump
and he's going to throw me under the bus
why not go and try to make a deal right
now with prosecutors and with
investigators give them the goods spare
yourself what so clearly seems to be
upcoming am i off on this let me know
what you think send me a tweet at Deep
hackman or leave a reply in a comment if
you're watching on youtube what would
you do if you were in Rudy Giuliani's
shoes right now would you just say I'm
going down eventually let me make a deal
or do you try to keep up with the
neverending demands of how you maintain
loyalty and a friendly relationship with
Donald Trump let me know what you think
after the break we will talk about Jean
sort of reverse psychology by the French
president Emmanuel macron we will also
get to a very very interesting voicemail
from a right-winger which I think you
will find both compelling and disturbing
all of that coming up after this quick
break